beijing a city of more than 20 million
people almost at a standstill
schools gyms hairdressers all closed and
people are being told or forced to work
from home while widespread covert 19
testing's underway
we must work hard to race against the
virus adhere to the 24-hour treatment
rule carry out the epidemiological
investigations controls and detection
and fast manner and speed up the whole
process
but with the toughening restrictions in
beijing and the weeks of lockdown misery
in the biggest city shanghai the world
health organizations issued rare
criticism of china's zero-covered
strategy
we have discussed about this issue with
chinese experts
and we
indicated that the approach
you know
will not be sustainable and considering
the behavior of the virus
i think a shift will be very important
experts suggest china could struggle to
find a way out because of low
vaccination rates and those aged over
60.
over the long term
millions
countless millions of people in china
are going to get covered
and they need a strategy to prevent
people from being hospitalized and dying
and that really means
effective
vaccines and high penetration
particularly among the elderly and the
vulnerable and that's not happening in
china
china's policies have caused anger and
anguish for separating children from
parents and putting those without
symptoms in with others who are unwell
they've been rare protests too with
residents in shanghai banging pots and
frustration over weeks spent indoors
here crowds faced off with police and
protective clothing because their homes
were being turned into temporary
quarantine centres
but all of those actions as we've said
since the beginning should be
showed due respect to individual and
human rights and we always have said as
who that we need to balance the control
measures against the impact they have on
society the impact they have on the
economy and that's not always an easy
calibration to me
while other countries have shared a zero
covert approach are beginning to
transition to living with the virus
china is yet to move on it says its
policies will stand the test of history
vowing to win the battle against the
pandemic alex o'brien al jazeera